you are
only the central intelligence
this is all a game of identity
shift your identity from being a person
to being the creationary force
itself
shift your identity to the big bang
become the entire planet and
all of the people
interacting
become the entire creationary force
if you can shift your identity to being
the entire creationary force
then you can become god
you can recognize yourself as god
god has always been in this diamond
around your neck
but you're so arrogant that you keep
separating yourself from
god you keep separating yourself from
the creationary force itself
there's only one intelligence present at
play with itself it's the central
intelligence and it's what's happening
right now this
moment is this civilization
at play with itself as one intelligence
this is one out of infinite possibility
this is a manifestation of eternity
but you're so arrogant to contract
yourself into a person identity
and separate yourself from the one
intelligence you basically are a person
saying that i'm separate from the big
bang
that's what you're doing
that's arrogant
i was also doing that
awakening is
shifting identity from being a separate
person to being the entire creationary
force
then once you see as everything is god
interacting with itself
then you no longer can commit
malevolence
because you know everything is you
everything's one intelligence
just look into the pupil at the center
of everyone's eye
it's the same pupil it's the same
source it's the same
one intelligence
playing with itself from different
perspectives
enjoying its grand creation of a planet
orbiting a star
with a civilization that has this very
specific
history and these very specific
challenges
in this very specific geopolitics and
geoeconomical climate
with these very specific countries and
this very specific
eight billion forms and appearances
and costumes that they're wearing
but it's all one intelligence if you
look at the pupil you'll see
the sameness the same source behind it
all
but you're attached to the geopolitics
you're
attached to your country you're attached
to your religion you're attached to your
career you're attached to your identity
you're attached to your name
and your attachments in the perpetuation
of those
attachments is what creates the massive
argument because you think you're
separate from other people and you don't
see it as one intelligence
look at the pupil go all the way into
the pupil
of every single person and what you'll
see is the exact
same source that is witnessing its
creation
there's one source one intelligence
witnessing observing experiencing
infinite creation
and planet earth is one dreamed
example it's a manifestation of
eternity there was never a beginning and
there is never going to be an
end you'll never come to the end of all
possibilities ever
ever and you've had mathematicians and
logicians
for hundreds of years try and tell you
that
you'll never come to the end of all of
the possibilities
mathematically that's what we are
metaphysically
you'll never come to the end of eternity
you'll never come to the end of infinity
you are the creator you are the very
source
of this one intelligence at play with
itself
but you're deluded and contracted and
distorted
into a separate finite person identity
and you're trying to extract peace and
happiness from relationships and
substances and experiences and material
possessions
and you're causing havoc and suffering
in the civilization
the number one thing you can do is just
learn
how to shift your identity
constitutionalize yourself away from
personhood and towards god
recognize yourself as god as the one
intelligence
there is only one central intelligence
present and at play with itself that is
all god
stop being a separate person shift your
identity
constitutionalize yourself in the new
shift in identity
to being the [ __ ] creator of it all
see everyone as the creator of it all
if you look into their pupils you will
see the same witness the same
eye the same god
but you're not subtle enough all you're
focused on are the differences
and that's the point of our creation is
to create this very
a sleeping mechanism where we forget and
then have to remember
in the forgetting or the a sleeping
process or the hiding process
we think we are separate and we're so
arrogant
and in the remembering in the awakening
in the seeking process we turn inward
and we stop arguing
with god we stop being separate
and in that turn inward we stop creating
suffering because we recognize our true
nature as a cameo an appearance of
eternity of infinity as the creator
itself
and we begin seeing everything as that
shift your identity to seeing everything
as one intelligence at play with itself
and liberate yourself from suffering
it's all about identity this entire
creationary game is about identity
shift your identity as fast as possible
from being a
separate person to being god
to being the very source to being the
very one intelligence at play with
itself
and see that everywhere you look moving
forward as this is
all one intelligence at play with itself
exploring
experiencing having this beautiful fun
dream
until you make that shift from person to
creator
you will suffer
and you will
laugh at yourself when you awaken
because of your arrogance and because of
all the suffering that you perpetuated
shift your identity to the creator you
are
only the central intelligence
there is only one intelligence at play
with itself
become the entire big bang
in the entire creationary force itself
if you can make that
one shift from being a i'm a tiny little
human
on a planet that is completely random
with a bunch of other tiny separate
humans that are completely random
two i am the [ __ ] big bang
itself and the entire creationary force
itself and all of the people on the
planet
at play with itself exploring
if you take on that identity you win the
game
you become lucid in the dream
become lucid in the dream
awaken to
the identity as the one intelligence at
play with itself
and then serve the creation rather than
trying to
extract greedily from the creation
it's so arrogant
when you believe you are a separate
finite
entity in the one intelligence you
believe you're separate and
from it that you then go
on to try and extract
from it and get peace and happiness
from it because you don't know it is you
now albeit this is all part of the
creationary game
but the faster that you stop doing that
that you stop
identifying with yourself as a finite
separate
person from the one intelligence
the faster you can stop creating
suffering
the faster you stop arguing with god the
faster you reunite with the kingdom of
god that is within you
and the faster that you serve your
creation because you see it all as one
intelligence
shift your identity from being a person
to being the [ __ ] creationary force
itself
become awakened become lucid in the
dream
it's all about the shift in identity
you are only the intelligence behind the
whole play
and you'll notice that once you shift
your identity to being the one
intelligence at play with itself
you'll notice that you'll have your
personhood conditioning
arise while you are trying to maintain
the awareness of everything being one
intelligence at play with itself
so you'll try to be serving the creation
and then you'll notice that your little
conditioning will arise
your personhood contracted identity
where it's trying to seek validation
or try and extract some sort of
happiness
and what you'll do is you'll become more
and more aware
of that over time and you'll purify it
separation and victimhood are arrogance
you are not
separate this is the one intelligence at
play with itself
and you are not a victim you are the
[ __ ] creator of this reality
but you're stuck in the person identity
and you have
to shift whether you like it or not the
shift is coming
so you may as well sovereignly decide
now to shift you may as well
take this moment right now to reflect
inward hmm
am i a person
if the answer is yes then practice
daily seeing yourself as the big bang
and as the very creationary force that
is at play
on this planet
the more that you do that and you stop
seeing yourself as a separate person
from the one intelligence the more
you'll awaken
faster and then fight off your person
conditioning
and then become a true steward a true
shepherd to the creation awakening
look in the pupil of everyone's eyes
and you will see the very source the
very nothingness
that we arise from that comprehends
the entire play that is happening be
the very source that births
the creationary force and then
comprehends
its play
be the very source that births
the creationary force and then
watches the play
and this is but one of an
infinite amount of plays
wake up to that and wake up to your true
nature
thank you
you